so what comes in your mind when you hear
the term
cloning if you're like me
then you might be thinking of the clone
warriors from the star wars movie right
now let me tell you that it's not only
clone warriors but cloning
could be done for anything such as
dna there could be clones of dna
there could be clones of sale there
could be even clones of
this cat in fact
the identical twins are clone of each
other that simply means
clone are exactly similar
things right now the question is
is it possible to make a clone of an
animal
sounds pretty sci-fi right and it turns
out
it is possible and it was possible
because
in 1996 there was an experiment by
prof keith campbell and ian wilmot
and the experiment took place in the
roslin institute scotland
and they cloned dolly so
introducing dolly the sheep so why dolly
is so special
it turns out dolly is actually a clone
of a fin dorset e now
dolly the sheep was pretty popular even
still now she's pretty popular
because she was fertile she can give
rise to offsprings and she was exactly
same
to his mother to her mother
in terms of genetic makeup
so let us try to understand that how
dolly was created
so here is the mother of dolly who is a
fin dorset e
now from dolly's mother scientists took
the other cells which is the skin
cells from the mammary gland then from
a scottish blackfish blackface e
they took the egg cells
so the scottish blackface e work like an
egg donor
now they cultured the somatic cells
from the fin dorset and this somatic
cell culture would be used
later on but from the scottish blackfish
e
egg they took out the nucleus with the
help of a pipet
and these eggs now become enucleated
so note that there would be no genetic
material of scottish blackface e
in these in nucleated egg
now they use electric shock to fuse
these two cell types
the somatic cell and these egg cells
coming from the black faced e
now there would be a hybrid cell type
notice that in this hybrid cell type the
nucleus
or the genetic material would be totally
similar
to the somatic cell donor that means the
twin dorset whereas the cytoplasmic
material would be a mix-up between the
two
now these cells would ultimately
form an embryo and they would develop
gradually now when the embryo reach a
blastocyst stage
it is ready to be implanted to a
surrogate mother
in this case it is implanted to a
scottish blackfish e and when the
progeny was born
surprisingly enough the progeny was
exactly
similarly looking like the fin dorset ue
and they call it the dolly
dolly was the name given to these
newborn
lamp now dolly was the clone
of finn dorset e let me remind you
this finn dorset e work like a somatic
cell donor
so they are pretty much similar in terms
of their
genetic makeup right now dolly
was fully viable when dolly grew up like
her mother
she gave rise to bonnie bonnie was the
progeny of dolly and again
bonnie was exactly similar to dolly and
yup so bonnie was born out of dolly so
dolly was fully viable but eventually
dolly died now let me tell you
that cloning can bring industrial
revolution so let us
talk about the plus and negative point
of cloning
so let's think uh think from the
industrial point of view
so let us understand that we have a cow
farm and these cows are used for milk
or meat purposes so let's say there is a
cow which
gives a very good quality of milk and
very healthy so
it's a good source of meat as well so
this cow is a star of the farm
we wish that if we have multiple of
these cows then it would be really
beneficial
for the farm industry right or the meat
industry
so in theory we can generate the clones
of these star cow
and that would give us optimal quality
meat
and milk imagine how beneficial it would
be for the meat industry or the dairy
industry right
but there are ethical concerns in fact
scientists tried cloning in cows
and also in peaks keeping these things
in mind
obviously the cloning was successful
the progeny was born but due to some
unknown
reason these progeny were more
susceptible to
infections and they are dying so
it was expected that they would lower
the cost of farming and they would
really give rise to optimum quality of
meat and milk at
low cost but their maintenance was way
higher so still it's a problem
now while scientists were cloning cats
some dramatic came out of that so
this is a calico cat which was cloned
and her clone was genetically exactly
similar but look at her coat color
so identical dna but not non-identical
gaps
how that is possible that means even if
two organisms have
exactly similar genetic makeup they
might have differences
and these differences might occur at
epigenetic
level beyond genes right so
clones might not be exactly similar
now let us imagine the problem of
cloning and let us
try to understand so here is a pig
population
different colors represent different
genetic makeup of these pig
though they are same species but they
could be having
different gene expression profiles and
that makes them bit different from each
other
now if you start doing cloning over a
time period there would be exact
similar genetic makeup in a population
for a population
it's very bad because it cause inbreed
depression
or it increases the risk of genetic
disease
that really questions the
plus point of cloning because it
ultimately
it do not create genetic diversity
or it reduce the genetic diversity which
is very bad from an evolutionary point
of view
so but there could be benefits
think about the endangered animals we
know royal bengal tigers are endangered
their numbers
are very less one-horned rhinosaurus
polar bears elephant they're all
endangered only few thousands of them if
we don't take care of them
we if we don't conserve them then they
would be totally extinct from this earth
right
and they would be only left in the pages
of books
so using cloning method we can increase
their population
so let us imagine this is a royal bengal
tiger we can make a clone of this royal
bengal tiger
and that is how we can really increase
their population which is now
decreasing you know in a small
population there are problems like
genetic drift
and allelic fixation etc so we can
rescue them
from that small population but again
when the population would grow it would
be a homogeneous population of a tiger
that would create a huge problem that
would in turn
increase the risk of genetic disease so
well this problem is pretty pretty
complicated
even scientists tried this cloning
method to make
human organs inside a pig but that
eventually did not
lead to success now whether cloning is
good or whether cloning is bad it is
a alarming research ethical topic
and i can't really comment more on that
part
but anyway in this video we looked at
what is cloning how dolly was made
possible benefits of cloning and
possible downsides of cloning
that pretty much summarized this topic i
hope you enjoyed this video if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and you can support me
and my channel in patreon be my patreon
guys
and you can always access my course in
academy which is india's biggest
learning platform
using my code ap 10 you can get 10
discount
on my courses thank you guys